hi most of you know me I'm David
Thorburn director of the communications
forum let me begin by saying we're
missing as you may have noticed two
speakers those two speakers are
casualties in different ways of the
writers of the ending of the writers
strike and we'll have some things to say
about the writers strike shortly I
regret there the loss of Barbara hall
and Howard Gordon both of whom are
distinguished have distinguished careers
in television and would have had i think
many interesting things to say but I
must admit that I that I'm not
distraught over this fact because the
man to my right john romano an old
friend and and comrade of mine is among
the most articulate Hollywood folks I
know and as you'll see from what I'll
say in a few moments there are there is
a partial explanation for that by
articulate I mean capable of talking to
audiences in the way very good teachers
do john romano has been a writer and
producer on more than a dozen shows on a
dozen television shows including some
that he created himself among his among
the titles that John has has had has
worked on among the shows John has
worked on either as a writer or
sometimes as a writer producer sometimes
actually as the showrunner the
supervising producer who's responsible
for the whole for the whole activity of
the of the program among the shows that
he's been associated with our Hill
Street Blues let me look let me look at
my list because it's actually such an
impressive one Ashok a little-known show
that called Beverly Hills bunts which is
which was a spinoff of Hill Street Blues
a show called sweet justice which John
created he worked on it on Knots Landing
he he wrote the pilot episode of 24 he's
written episodes of monk he has was the
showrunner executive producer over a
number of seasons for American Dreams he
was the executive producer and a writer
on Third Watch
worked on Providence among two shows not
long-lasting shows but shows that
deserve a place in the in the Hall of
Fame of shows that lasted only a short
time but were intellectually and
artistically very distinguished our two
shows he created one with the debt with
the actor David Caruso called Michael
Hayes and another show a show very dear
to my heart because it was sort of said
in a college campus I kept hoping he
create a professor for burn on the show
but he never did a show called class of
96 so he's so he had has had a very
creative and productive career as a as a
television writer and and producer but
in recent years he's moved more and more
toward into the movies and and his his
screenwriting credits are impressive in
an even more remarkable way I think in
some degree his credits include the
third miracle the Coen Brothers film
intolerable cruelty a forthcoming film
starring Richard Gere called nights in
rodanthe all these things would make
john romano a remarkable an interesting
man in any in any environment but i
think that there's a side of his of his
career that I that is even more
interesting especially an interesting
profile for a television writer John has
a PhD from Yale where he got it where he
studied English under many very
distinguished professors and he after
earning his PhD at Yale he he took a job
in the English department at Columbia
University and was a beloved and much
admired young teacher at Columbia and
while he was at Columbia he wrote a
wonderful book an academic book and I
think he must be the only creator of a
television program who's published a
book with the Columbia University Press
about Charles Dickens it's a wonderful
book it's called Dickens and reality
it's a very thoughtful intelligent piece
of sophisticated literary criticism and
it's one of the reasons that I Treasurer
John as a writer and as a and as a
friend
it's really a very exciting one of the
one of the one of the few rewards you
get for getting old as a teacher is that
is that sometimes your students achieve
so much and come back and their guests
on forums that you run it's very very
exciting experience and I certainly feel
that about John about John's visit today
III thought that and the plan is to do
as we normally do with a forum John and
I will have a kind of conversation about
some matters related to television and
media for the first hour and then we'll
throw it open for questions and comments
from the audience we also have some
clips that we hope to show and John will
comment on them and I think this will
give us a hopefully a particularly
immediate insight into into the into the
into the art and commerce of television
John let's begin by by talking about a
bit about the strike Howard Gordon who
the the showrunner for 24 who was
supposed to have joined John on one of
the people who was supposed to have
joined John on the panel today sent me
an email the day after the writers
strike was solved was was was a ended
was what was resolved saying expressing
great apologies and saying he just hated
that that the he he was just overwhelmed
with with responsibilities now that the
strike had ended and he was sorry but
not to be able to do it Barbara whole
did not back out immediately although i
began to know I began to get uneasy
about it and but but apparently she the
pressure of work became so heavy on her
that she got it that she became ill and
she she had to back out much more
recently because because of illness and
I I am sorry about that my hope is both
of them will be able to return to a
forum at a later stage but let's turn to
the question of the strike John and
begin by but with with that and have you
make some comments about that there are
many people who feel that the that the
that the strike accomplished very little
for the riders and I and the first
question I have for you is do you think
that anything useful happened because of
the strike second question I've also
read a good deal by people commenting on
the strike
saying that they thought that the strike
signaled a change perhaps a fundamental
change in the economic structure of the
TV industry and I'm wondering if you
could begin by commenting on those
things well I'll take a second one first
it was too soon to know it kind of
change it to signals I i I'm sure it
signals change we live in a time when
it's you know the television industry is
being hit by all sorts of changes if we
were talking with some of your students
earlier about watching downloaded
episodes of lost and you know there's
just people sending out some people
catch up with 24 through little minutes
that are sent over your cell phone I
mean clearly this change and the way of
catching up with a show or getting or
watching a show exclusively through
through DVDs you buy in a box or going
on demand and deciding to catch up on a
show you didn't see watching every
episode of in treatment from the
beginning you know and these are all
things that we're not there 20 years ago
and in each case there's a financial
consequence and in each case as a writer
you say well so who makes money when my
sister backs up to see the episodes of
last season's a favorite show when
somebody makes money or they can I make
sure they're passing that on to me it's
simply about money um but you have to
understand that you wrote the darn thing
and the idea that some and you wrote it
to be up to be put on the air and now
someone has found another way of selling
it out of the back of their truck and
they had no intention of giving you a
piece of that and I mean I'm not the
world's biggest union guy I was not
active in the strike I participated in
the strike I did not break the strike I
carried to my daughter's amusement to
actually carry a sign and walked in the
picket line but I saw out you're not
talking to you know Tom Hayden here I'm
not
exactly the world's greatest union
organizer but there's a common sense
fairness that that you should
participate in the profits of your work
if other people are going to and if not
not and the studios I will say it's you
know this is no point reopening these
wounds but the studio's did seem to have
a kind of little wet dream that they
were actually going to UM profit from
the internet retransmission of old
television shows and not share the money
with anybody that really did seem to be
in their little minds and that's just
common sense common sense unfairness I
mean there's just a and that's all
without getting very excited because I
believe me I don't have it in me on
these subjects it seemed like zero
percent was probably the wrong number
and we can go from there and then the
number we ended up with was not very
exciting but it was better than zero and
the principal is on the table and that
was not there before and so good for us
I guess I hated being on strike so I
can't yeah it's why you're not getting
I'm not singing any Joe Hill songs or
anything but so those of you a mixed
verdict no no I think it was we got
something valuable it's on the it's now
it's now on the table it doesn't matter
that it isn't a lot of money the idea
that the principal was except yes you
can't you can't sell my stuff in any way
shape or form you know the comic book
version the novelization the one minute
on my cell phone the video game if I
wrote it you've got to give me something
of the money you're making by getting it
out there through those media that's all
it's I'm not it's not a religious
principle it's just this may have also
in part been a consequence of the strike
but I remember noticing in the every
monday the new york times in its
business section runs a a page that i'm
sure everyone in Hollywood looks at
closely it lists the
the movie grosses for the weekend it
lists the top-rated television shows
right and one of the things one of the
most interesting aspects of that of
those tables was the fact that it you
had to go down to number six or seven
before you came in terms of the number
of the programs that had gotten the
largest audiences you had to get down to
number six or seven before you came to a
story show a function show huh a series
whereas you know 15 years ago every
single show in the top 10 or 15 would
have been or almost every single show
unless there was a super bowl except for
60 minutes or 60 minute well even 60
minutes but yes we are right about that
60 minutes was always always membership
but but the number of the number of
fiction shows would be overwhelming on
those lists and that has declined now
part of it surely was the strike and
they'd stop putting some of the fiction
shows on during this time but even if we
allow for that John in the last five
years or so yeah a much larger number of
reality based nonfiction programs have
been getting audiences larger than the
fiction shows so the so one way into
this sort of broader conversation I want
to have with you has to do with what do
you think that it's actually a does it
feel to people in Hollywood like a kind
of permanent change that so much more of
prime time is now devoted to things that
are not stories that are not fiction not
series not movies well whether or do
they feel that that that stories will
return that little bit well the the the
quantitative answer trivially is that
you're you're right there used to be
most of the shows used to be story
script oriented character based
fictional narratives most of the shows
in the top 20 and now fewer than most
and I end but hit but the reality is
that if you if what you do for a living
if there are students in the audience or
people in the audience who who want to
tell stories and they want to tell them
in the format of television um there is
and probably will be for the foreseeable
future always an appetite for
the next really terrific one on and any
executive who is here if you you should
have executives here you should have
people who dress better than myself and
and look at it things from the corporate
side some of them are you know
remarkable creative individuals men and
women believe it or not and they would
say look if someone walks to the door
and tells me a story you taped the top
of my head off about people that he or
she made up I'm going to bet that it's
going to take off the the same head and
the large numbers of people I bet
there's money in that that sounds great
to me let's do it there always be an
appetite for that now what's changed is
that on the networks on the five
networks and you know and they're there
they're closely related cable stations
like USA FX arm there the notion of what
makes a story and characters thrilling
is more aggressive less literary less
about the language higher concept crazy
or faster and if you have an idea which
really has to do with the transactions
between human beings if you're sort of
more on the Jane Austen end of things
than on the JJ Abrams anything you're
probably going to go you're in and you
know this happens to me every well
everyone who JJ Abrams is I think it's a
tova no Jane Austen is um the cheek of
it they all know who she has more movies
out than he does you know he's a better
movies created of a creator of like lost
and alias those kinds of television
shows and and and as opposed to Jane
Austen um if you're if you're closer to
the character narrative storytelling end
of things if you get this if if your
imagination is giving you really into
your your mind interesting sexy
attractive moves within the recognizable
normal human psyche with the ordinary
number of heads and arms and and taking
place on this planet and roughly linear
time if that's where your imagination
takes you you'll probably take your idea
to
HBO or Showtime and unless you're less
likely to think that you're restricted
to the five networks if it has a big
star in it attached if you've decided to
tell this idea to your friend David
Caruso and he wants to do the show with
you you probably go to CBS and if it has
six incredibly good-looking young people
that's the nature of idea who just can't
leave each other's little bodies alone
you probably take it to ABC so there
there are you know you have a direction
a sense of sort of directionality but
they the they'll still be a place there
are fewer places and you have to pick
your shots more carefully but there's
still a place for a narrative
storytelling and yes you've done the
numbers correctly there are more
so-called reality shows and more other
types and kinds of things competitions
and you know and show still training
runway so they can clearly they were
there were many factors that that change
the nature of broadcast broadcast work
out of what you're saying maybe I heard
but no no I missed the real interest of
your question the real answer question
is why strike now given you already have
a problem fiction TV writer yes which is
that all these other shows or types and
kinds of shows well yes I mean that's
true and a lot of people said we have
enough troubles with the rise of it with
fewer people watching a ordinary
dramatic television to suddenly make
that business is getting is losing
enough of its flavor for the studios and
networks why make it even harder by
cutting into their imagine profits from
New new media and that's true that's a
good case to make sitting around the
fire or walking in the picket line but
there remains for many of us are kind of
again what I just call common sense
fairness that you know if well if
they're as long as they're making some
of them and I wrote some of them I want
some of the money some of the profit
shift let's shift to up to your lated
subject okay there were many wait money
as I start
to say there were many factors help to
explain how network programming
especially fiction program has changed
since you entered the business in 1980
and and what wasn't one could make an
argument that that the period from the
mid seventies sometimes through the
mid-80s was a very very remarkable time
in television history maybe its most
creative time from the standpoint of
fiction programming but one and and
there are obviously a part of the
explanation for what happened there has
to do with competition from cable and
the proliferation of channels and so
forth but one thing that many people
have said and I wonder what your
reaction is I know you have something
interesting things to say about this is
that is that the events of 911 had a
profound impact on the content of
television on the kinds of stories that
were being told on television and it and
I wondered if you would comment on that
a bit and to talk to us about how you
felt how you feel the events of 911
affected programming and attitudes
toward programming attitudes towards
stories and characters well sir
certainly were just having a very good
discussion about the show lost and that
it reflects a kind of post 9-11 paranoia
kind of well I shouldn't call paranoid
there's genuine fierce that's taking
here but a sense that we are an island
arm threatened by a strange alien
creatures i mean new xenophobia in this
and that we only have each other to
depend on and who knows whether we can
depend on each other I mean there's
certainly 911 did its fair share to feed
a lot of impulses not all of which are
admirable some are just you know
xenophobia and so forth but also it get
it also did a sense that i thought was
palpable these are let me a little
random in my answer um take for example
the the current coen brothers movie No
Country for Old Men and the evil Javier
Bardem character our friend Leo Brody
made a very good point about this
character aside from the fact that he's
of sort of in the movie of indeterminate
a foreign origin and he is an implacable
evil with the kind of psychology less a
non humanistic interior so that the evil
seems to be sort of presentational
surface evil with nothing behind it
which is I think the technical term is
scary on the screen and it
resonates with something in the audience
which may not have been there before
nine eleven so that we're the interest I
find it a valuable in creatively you
know it's useful in as Robert thrusts at
about the poor they're useful in my work
there I find the idea that there's such
a thing as good and evil is actually of
help to a storyteller so that everything
isn't always about how are you feeling
today you know and so I'm feeling today
and the answer to all problems when I
was running part of your father used to
say it seems this is the world in which
the answer to almost everything is a hug
and that's actually the world is
actually much more interesting than that
911 represents that that part of our
human experience which is not answerable
by a hug it doesn't mean it's answer by
the Patriot Act but it's not answerable
by a hug so it that's that makes stories
almost as interesting as the real world
which remains still the winner in any
context or what's the most entertaining
and unbelievable you're offering a kind
of positive in its in this not that
you're saying that there's an
aesthetically positive well known Isis
it's very I thought you were going to
say jail all the television programs
became fascist shows about how you
should torture people well you know
don't forget I work in the pi over 24 I
mean I I think that we're going to show
but which we're going to show you well
but the point is the thing the interest
the human interest of a show like that
is look what you want to do you had
David Meltzer who has a great deal a
great deal to teach and one of the
things that David taught when I was a
kid on Hill Street Blues I think 150
years ago was that just his instructions
were as you went into
to write just jam your character up make
things as hard for him or her as
possible when you're done making him
that possible you're done hand it in
we'll shoot it that's the job that's the
task well if you want to look at a
positive side to 911 I mean lightning is
surely going to strike if you make too
much of this but the truth is that it's
a very it presents it certainly makes
thinking about international relations
more difficult and the the dilemma of
Kieffer in 24 and I think that if Howard
were here had been able to come we would
have had a good time talking about the
subsequent history of the show because
he's been involved in recent years i was
only there at the beginning the dilemma
that you're serving him the genuinely
interesting dilemma if you don't think
this is interesting you're simply
mistaken not about the quality of the
show but about the nature of the dilemma
is that there's such a thing as evil out
there to fight I'm not saying it gets
characterized with with political
accuracy in any given a manifestation of
paranoia that comes out of Hollywood or
out of the the Atlantic for that matter
but um I'm saying that suddenly it says
you can't answer it by by sitting down
and act for and being touching knees and
being very sensitive and clear kind of
writing i love doing by the way this is
but this is aggressively his aggressive
the case the kefir must be a human being
must cope with his daughter his family
his own limitations his own the fact
that he is within himself not in control
out of control as a person and yet it is
his task to do something about something
which a threat which is really out there
now if you premise that that the there's
no threat really out there that the only
threat you can think of is the
republicans winning in november as a
part of me that might agree with you but
we're both wrong there's a good deal
more to be concerned about and the idea
of both taking that on and remaining in
touch with your humanity for which read
father husband person kid who used to
you know play with marbles is now
it is now torturing or being torch I
mean the truth is those narrative human
dilemmas which can't be comfortably
solved which are not the simple
knockoffs of any particular political
position when the human being transcends
politics um you're you've got something
interesting to talk about have they
served it well you know I feel more
comfortable saying that they haven't if
Howard we're here to defend it but
there's no question that the dilemma is
an authentic one awaiting our next
president I certainly agree about that
yeah I mean my own responses to the
question away has to do not so much with
any individual show but with the
proliferation of law and order kinds of
programs you know as it seems to me that
one explanation about the impact of 911
is just to say that the country was
terrified into a situation in which or
at least Hollywood felt the country was
terrified into a situation in which it
needed to have programs that reassured
it that all of its law enforcement
agencies were hooked up to the best
technology possible and we're geniuses
that last minute torture and that's well
the interesting thing about the
proliferation of technology centered on
the inside of 24 that simply bores me I
don't watch very often the sight of 24
simply bores me is it's techno spy stuff
but if you look at shows like CSI if you
can bear it the thing about that about
that kind of writing is that yes it has
a naive faith that that somehow you will
invent the right widget me I'm here at
MIT it's a lively question but the
interest but but the the taste for and
the acknowledgment of complexity there
is no widget that will saw you will
still have to make decisions about
deploying and those decisions you will
always make a little bit blind you will
always see us through a glass darkly
that is this that's the deal so get by
all means let's work on better ones so
bad technology forensics entered shows
are the ones that pretend that the cool
toy solves the problem good ones show
the limitations and the fact that
nothing will ever replace what a TS
Eliot said there is no method except to
be very intelligent and nothing ever
relieves you know method all
oh gee will ever relieve you of those
human the lemons nor will any rightness
right feeling nor will any way of like
no no ideology no way this is me talking
and perhaps I'm mistaken but but no way
no correct way of looking at the world
is going to spare you how complex
problems are when stories say that
they're doing a good job I have respect
for a show you don't like very much
which is dick will slow and water and I
think in its early days I haven't seen
all the incarnations and I don't like
see it the the the ones with like a
colon and something after law and order
and all my stuff but the original Law &
Order with like Sam Waterston and those
incredible people around them they they
were great shows and the reason is a you
didn't know whether they we are the team
we're rooting for cops and then
prosecutors would win or not and be you
didn't know whether they should win or
not and see they didn't know whether
they should win or not and he always
kept those three things in play and if
like me you find yourself watching the
same ones late at night over and over
again it's because the ending is not an
ending because they had true respect for
the fact that yeah this this is a lawyer
doing a great job really well this is a
cop doing a great job really well guess
what I don't know whether it should go
this way and I don't know how it's going
to go and that kind of respect for the
stubborn so you a writer's argument
about the complexity yeah about the
about the barley just a mullet explicity
of the show yeah yep and I think it just
you know again bluntly speaking it makes
for better stories and makes for more
fun but it's also true about the world
from my um well graspable one way we can
concretize some of John's right early
passion is by looking at particular
passage and we are going to now show you
a clip can we do this can we make a 20
shillings your attention we're going to
do the 24 first oh the first few min
we've got it covered that point right
well let's show the clip and you can you
can you can say very little about it but
I want people to see as quickly okay I
move on can you find it fast
what is the next clip the next is Hill
Street you want to do the nun all can do
this because I thought if we ran out of
time we would you well know you can you
i mean i think i think twenty four
seventy percent one reason i want to do
this is to concretize some assurance a
nature you know it's it's one thing to
think in sort of abstract terms okay
let's say and one of the things about
Romano is he is that he he actually has
the job of writing a scene in his head
whenever he's talking and it's a I think
it will be helpful for you did you need
to is this it can we freeze it for a
second sure John you want to give a
context for this there uh is it did you
start with the house uh there's no
contact this is that this is the first
five minutes of the first show of
Missouri audience saw it without context
they saw his very first episode of yeah
so they had no context so which john
rowe go ahead right I rewrote I rewrote
they had it they had a good idea for a
show and it was going to take place in
24 hours every week and I mean yeah
every I'm sorry it was going to be an
hour every week for 24 episodes and that
would be your season but it would be
real time our they did as you know if
you they didn't stay with that
eventually became you know every show
was 24 I mean it was just to argue as to
do real time for seven years but um that
was they had that idea that had the idea
of Jack and this sort of supra
Intelligence Agency and the idea that
the first season would be about a
planned assassination alas of a black
candidate for the US president all right
so here's Romano's revision of the first
of the his revised versions diversity
shot innocent more or less his rewrite
you know she still giving you the cold
shoulder
if I she referring to your mother I'd
appreciate it if you called her by her
name mom I know she's just busy she's
busy a lot it's a school night for you
so time for bed you lie to move back and
daddy into Suri have a good sleep
she stood giving a hard time if she
plays need for you moving out I never
gave her any reason I think you let her
manipulate you jack don't let me guess
just now she was all sweetness and light
right but she said something nasty about
me yeah and I just busted her own well
you're taking this so personally just a
mother teenage daughter thing
you're right maybe we should talk to her
right now tell me she can't play us off
each other she's insulting issues of
something me too
so you just said that you appreciate
that do mean your time they'll
appreciate it really really appreciate
it really appreciate it
dan
she's grounded for two months no
exceptions she can forget about getting
a driver's license oh yeah your phone
call I'm the only I'd say about that in
relation to what i said that's only just
another mildred call and exfoliation
idea would be that every line from I I
think you should call her by her real
name mom which obviously isn't her name
too um I became the enemy right to their
manipulating you Jack to all of those
have almost have palpable kind of spy
military reality right it's as if one is
saying that the distinction between
domestic life and political life has
been really has evaporated or and you
can't I mean it was also deliberately a
bland ordinary scene which has happened
I mean in my house any number of nights
through my daughter's teenage years I
mean it was deliberately underwritten
and simply didn't play chess as I'm ago
uh it was deliberately something that
might happen in any home but it was
haunted by the political realities which
are his job he's a spy so when you said
him you're being manipulated or you're
lying or when he says I got a good idea
let's tell her we can't play she can't
play both of us off each other you don't
hear anything you can't hear in many of
our kitchens but you're also hearing
something you might well here in the
back rooms at National Security Agency
there's a kind of sense in which is
those lives so that's the kind of thing
that that I have in mind both those were
also come now it turns out she's not
just gone she wouldn't be the first
teenage girl to jump out the window I
mean to leave but very few are being
abducted by international spies but but
you can you see the point
really that I'm making these are
essentially human the political bloomers
are essentially human dilemma is the
human Delilah's have a political
dimension and that's where we is what
John were you implying what I feel is
the case is that as 24 1 on it it became
less and less interested in that human
dimension yeah I think there was no i
don't think the development of and i
don't really want to say too much about
the show I mean that they're certainly
certainly been it's like a lot of the
search politics have damaged its its
social its manners it's the its sense of
civility and decency I mean it's a lot
to say but the show I never you know the
torture stuff was again without Howard
here I don't want to come well I'm we're
going to skip to the third example but i
but I mean didn't have a reaction I
throwing off your format no no no that's
fine because I mean let me look I'm the
bossy okay no I know so look what I mean
I just showed him a piece but I want I
what I want to do now is I want to I
want to show you another clip to give
you so show you in a way another side of
John another shot side of television one
of the most interesting things about
American television in the 80s and 90s
in part because of competition from so
many new sources and the proliferation
of channels was that in an odd way
broadcast television the television that
we associate with the major networks he
came in its own way very experimental
and there were whole series of programs
that appeared in the 80s and 90s some of
which lasted only a few only a few
episodes they often had more episodes in
the can than they actually showed
because the the the networks were so
impatient not allowing them to generate
an audience if they got very low ratings
they would knock them off the air very
quickly and one such program is is it
for me it's sort of the embodiment of
this whole group of programs there there
must be at least a dozen such shows
series television programs that took
liberties with various generic
expectations and here is a particularly
dramatic example of such a program in
its introduction it uses a scene in a in
a police station a roll call
it's very explicit allusion to the way
in which Hill Street Blues ohm almost
always began almost always the very
first scene in Hill Street Blues was a
scene in the in the at roll call where
the sergeant-at-arms would be giving
assignments to various people and the
EPPA the scene you're about to see it's
from the I think the first episode of
this program not be from a recent
episode and from from one of the very
few that were broadcast it was only on
1111 em right this is from maybe the
second or third week but doesn't matter
i mean because it's the very beginning
of the show but you'll get you'll get a
sense of what's going on there night
you'll see why i haven't mentioned the
title even though you probably were able
to read it on the screen to go look at
this item 7 november 29 3 p.m. conflict
resolution seminar in this room
attendance mandatory you got conflict
with that yeah I do it's resolved you're
going to meet officer Quinn returns to
active duty roster tomorrow so Jaeger
you'll ride to cerrito oh it's breaking
we party keggers got yak breath I camera
so wear a gas mask item last on the
teletype we still got the Franklin
Avenue flasher struck at two outdoor
weddings in a school picnic so far this
month male 63 look for tattoos and
unusual places okay that's it and hey
hey let's be careful out
four squares and throwing a ball to the
catcher
okay all right sorry you couldn't get
the whole song would come up to oh yeah
I'm sure that does in fact I mean the
show is called cop rock and it was a
police musical a really a cop opera
really and every John can describe it
more fully than I because we worked on
the drive that every every episode
had a number of original songs in it
right a midwife so five in every episode
one of the things that went wrong is
that Steven Bochco declared decreed that
we would have five songs in every show
this meant that if three of them were
okay and two of them were less than okay
we were still going to have five songs
in every show right now you know a bad
scene you can get a sandwich I mean a
bad song you just flipped it you know I
mean a bad song is well I i don't
remember John were you here before when
I showed that I've shown this I've
showed this once before at the forum and
it got much more of a reaction than you
folks Bree I mean you don't know that
maybe maybe a very strong reality but
but unexpressed maybe so but it would
the show was a catastrophe from every
and in fact John was embarrassed when I
first mentioned it in public John was
embarrassed as if it were it has a huge
following it has a it has a young it has
a following it you know people are trio
recently made a documentary about the
making of cop rod but it's a slightly
bemused you know it has a huge camp
following I can tell you in a sense of
camp but it also a lot of people liked
it as long as you what do you think went
wrong well I think we'll listen I think
that you'll learn something you know
here's the three rules of history you
know you know march on Moscow you don't
find a land war in Asia and you don't
make cops saying on television those are
those I think what we learned making cop
Rock I'll tell you something interesting
about what really went wrong on the
first episode had songs by Randy Newman
and they were a great songs and then we
had a man broke the Rossum and i want to
say men decrow that we have some very
good
songwriters Donnie Markowitz you know I
mean it was just they were good song
writers but they weren't you know they
were being asked to write five come up
with five songs original songs a week I
mean you know Lerner and Loewe II didn't
do five it just not the way musicians
work so it was defeated by that premise
but it was defeated I think even if you
did have a you know John Lennon and
Elton John writing your music or
something you could not have done the
show in that company because that group
of men and women who did the who did
Hill Street and then they did eventually
they didn't want NYPD Blue and you know
that that crew um music requires a kind
of non-ironic among other things
requires a nonionic soul I mean you have
to be able to look into the eyes of
someone you love and say I'm yours you
can't do that as a writer as an artist
you shouldn't be writing musicals they
really they can't all be wise cracks
like this one when it works that's fine
you know you should have a few of those
in every you know great musical but you
also have to be able to to be direct and
ironic and the strength of that very
gifted group of people who did such
great a television like a lot of the
work of that generation the one directly
preceding my own TV generation is marked
by a sense that all great art is a
little bit you know the call the curses
of high modernism it's always I ronik
all emotions are a little bit
sentimentality walks with the devil you
know all the all the things that made
the literature of the 20s and 30s and
40s and 50s great I mean that their
favorite a writer is JD Salinger the
world in which their sensibility was
formed as a deeply ironic a tearing of
the veil of ordinary bourgeois society
there's a kind of a contempt at its
heart for the kinds of emotion that I
think make for better songs I'm just
speaking as you know you don't really
kind of kind of want to read a lot of
songs which say I love you but I got to
go now the boys are waiting which is so
the the tone of the world of Steven
Bochco so but this is an avid medicine
this is an aesthetic judgment John what
I what my question is right over there
we want going why didn't the show work
with audiences why didn't people watch
because it because they want they want I
love you they want feeling they want
true people are entitled to feel
something they don't they don't always
want to be smirking at the you know the
you know you just can't live on it on a
diet of wisecracks I remember I talked
to you on the telephone when you were
working on this show and I remember
because I was excited about something i
was watching on television I said well
yeah and you kept telling me don't tell
me your ideas because I'm working on
this character now and remember we we
actually had an argument because it was
as if it was as if John didn't want to
be John didn't want to be distracted
from his sense that that that the
materials he was working with how to
kind of a kind of original excitement
form that he didn't want corrupted by
sort of academic discourse and the truth
is I remember genuine intellectual
excitement in you especially about the
central plot this show actually was a
very advanced Joe and a lot of well it
had it had a dream where is that them
one of the protagonists is a cop who
ends up going to jail yeah but you know
but he but that again you know it's sort
of the dirty cop who had to do what he
had to do and put them on the wrong side
of the authorities I mean there's a kind
of it seems to me the informing cultural
precepts of that show and perhaps of
Hill Street Blues in its way it's a
greater show seemed to me long in the
tooth in a way that as an artist you
always have to be conscious of it seemed
to belong to the side of post-war um
writing and art that sort of felt the
more cynical you were the smarter you
probably were that all great art is
fundamentally ironic and that that is
you can see that we're we're talking
about a very successful example of a
movie which I admire and work with Coen
brothers but but the movie no country
for old men you know embodies that you
can see how smart I am because you see
how
depressed and cynical and this and
fundamentally essentially dissenting I
am and now I think that movie really is
really worth seeing really good I've you
know we we did a movie call on Tolliver
cruelty that's an interesting I don't I
think we saw intolerable cruelty you
like the movie how many song tolerable
cool okay and um good I'm glad you like
it they made a change in the direction
that I'm talking about me well I think
the problem with in tolliver cruelty
perhaps for those who are not as excited
about it um was that it everybody in it
is kind of a bad guy she she's as much a
thief and liar and and she's a marriage
pirate you know she goes from marriage
to marriage stuffing her pockets as she
divorces you and she takes on the
world's most talented divorce lawyer and
gets him to fall in love with her on the
grounds that she's Catherine zeta-jones
and looks great that's the device of the
movies actually the khan brothers are
such skillful movie makers they told the
makeup people we want her to look like
gold and they said oh yeah Sheila great
they said no no gold as in a you gold we
want her to look like gold that is we
want the make up to actually have a gold
tent because she's about money and
that's how we're gonna shoot her and
suited her hair and ice but that's what
they did mean they're incredibly
meticulous filmmakers and brilliant i'm
not saying anything about that but
they're in there in my version she was
an ordinary housewife whose husband left
her took her to the cleaners and and she
decided to get even by getting this
divorce lawyer george clooney to fall in
love with her and she succeeds and takes
his money in their version she too has a
kind of marauding career and so it was
too bad guys against each other it
became there for about a thousand times
funnier and more entertaining than my
version and maybe it left a little less
maybe it had a little less impact
potentially on your feel on your
feelings
than than my version we will never know
I loved working with them and I think
it's you know a proud of the movie but
you'll see my credit is for story
because they went a whole other way with
with the making of the movie and it was
a similar thing and there and there and
there fairly you know young and and for
forward-looking filmmakers and the same
we might be said of the other Oscar
movie this year there will be blood that
it has a really nasty hard the sort of
ironic sort of modernist ironic
perspective talking about certainly
makes the argument makes great sense to
me John and I certainly see how it's
manifested especially in the movies come
commonly frequently I guess what and I
understand how elements like this can
get into television but it seems in fact
that such a sort of modernist and ironic
perspective would not be very tell it
that would not survive on television for
very long because there's always that
sort of claim of sentiment there's
always that claim of reassurance that at
least broadcast television with
everything on it I think scrubs is a
terrific show and it wears its feelings
very lightly but they're there it has
tremendous affection toward its
character yes it's really that's where
the silicon or changing is yeah but but
but but you have to but yeah everything
hard before calling it sentimental yes
but we one thinks of scrubs as a very
late whereas Gray's Anatomy is very
happy I mean Grey's Anatomy is both
sentimental and I think has no
particular weight and no but it's
certainly attractive and gives its
audience a good time so I don't think
you actually it's and it and I and I
don't I think it could be a lot better
so I don't think you necessarily achieve
great art by going the other way and in
their turn David and boch go and have
created really some of I think NYPD blue
is the best you can I wasn't anywhere
near that show I think it's the best you
can do I think that from me that was the
great show because there they really did
care about Sipowicz right and i think
that therefore they were invested beyond
the law and order of it I mean I created
the show I heard a show called sweet
justice with Cicely Tyson it was on for
a year
and the reason one of the reasons I i
created the show was I went to the
Oscars and I'm t Oscars the Emmys and
that I remember seeing that the clips
from best show and one was NYPD blue in
which buns takes an accused man a perp
which means in our system an accused a
man accused of being a criminal which
means on our system by the way that he's
innocent in case you haven't noticed or
you're John Ashcroft he takes an accused
Matt and slams him into the wall and he
says I'm going to get a migraine tonight
because I can't you know smash your
forehead in right now because of the
Bill of Rights or some or something like
that and then the next clip was for
picket fences and it was a ray walton or
somebody i think being a judge and David
Kelly who's a lawyer had written this
series and the judge is saying in the
clip they showed was saying isn't it a
shame the way you know we have to let on
so many you know criminals go free
because of technicalities and I thought
here's a judge talking about
technicalities well what the heck else
do you do as a judge but worry about
whether the laws technical you know
rules have been followed exactly where
and I thought both of these shows are
being a you know promoted and have huge
audiences and I've enjoyed episodes of
both I mean as I said NYPD Blue atha
spectacular show but both of them took
as a premise you see that what the
audience wanted was that we should be
slamming the accused no matter what so I
created a show about um about defense
attorneys well no one has really been
able to make a successful show about
defense attorneys I mean Boston Legal is
as good as you get it gets and Boston
Legal Rights those I mean no one has
ever leave it at that no one's ever been
able to to make a show at defense
attorneys and I would confront a botch
going they had no sympathy in the in the
for 25 years I mean there have been
chosen the long he
stria well maybe I mean I am sorry the
last way Marilyn in fact I mean it's an
interesting fact that the term that the
medium has in some sense become but but
I run it but I love but no but I believe
in the market to this extent if people
if the if there were a tremendous
yearning in the audience to see someone
defend criminals and for that to be your
hero we would have had more than the few
examples that we have of shows that even
pretend you know to do that um it is so
I mean I think the audience is at the
audience is in a very law and order mood
no doubt your point is well-taken 911
reinforces that and these shows have
catered to it with their own anxiety and
cynicism about the social fabric and and
I wouldn't say the right wing by the way
as everyone knows everybody who writes
in Hollywood's the more or less liberal
Democrat if you can count the exceptions
I want you can print that if you like
this is I'm going to this isn't the last
question I'll ask and then we'll open it
up to questions from the audience so
prepare your questions but junk on the
base of something you've just said yeah
I I was going to ask you to say a little
bit about what you and I have sometimes
called and I've actually seen referred
to in print as the Yale and Harvard
mathy lot of guys who write for
television I think the point is that
when you went off to work on television
there was already a group of former Yale
graduates who were working in television
that was how you got the that was your
contact yeah I looked a little bit of it
you talk them a little bit about I think
the only the only aside from the sort of
bula-bula of it the only thing of it
that's important about it is the
following that TV is made by um dropout
English majors um from good universities
not necessarily Harvey he'll only and
that it it it's if there is a when I got
into it in the late 80s Early 90s there
was a literary inheritance which was
always present I mean you know it can be
it can be overwhelming sometimes I mean
remember you know walking down the
hallway at mtm the old studio that
produced st. elsewhere and Remington
Steele and Hill Street Blues and all and
they'd say let's do stephen crane's the
blu hotel only will use our characters
and in every one knew what he was
talking about more or less i mean you
know you know that was pretty surprising
i think that ship has sailed
I think now you have a generation of
really good really smart really talented
young filmmakers who for reasons of
their own actually prefer TV to movies
but their origins that the pictures in
their head derive from movies from
television from graphic media different
kinds they're not originally they
certainly not playwrights and nobody
goes to the theater and there I mean I'm
talking about the kinds of numbers
masses that that you need to produce a
popular culture and what's become of
reading is well familiar story i should
think I mean so the arm their their
sensibilities are not founded on texts
are not founded on language it's all it
already comes in visualized form that
being said boy are they talented boy are
they cool boy there's a lot of
interesting stuff being done but there
is from me that will always seem to me
to be some it's a little harder for me
to get at some of the interesting
wrinkles of this this humanoid crowd if
you don't have access to language and if
words aren't inset centrally and play in
your drama um and that doesn't mean that
all tell dean has to look like in
treatment which is a camera that goes
back and forth between two talking
people terrific show um but it does mean
that that basically you know take away
the word and there's just not much you
can say about these these bipeds that
will really claim me as an arts inspire
me that but but the truth is that these
lot of young filmmakers are not they're
not devoid of language j-just it's just
like the language already comes in
visual form it's already moving they're
already moving pictures I suspect there
are limits to what that's going to that
that direction is going to be able to
say or achieve but remember the Henry
the
begins with Shakespeare saying Oh for a
stage of what is a ring of fire over the
first thing he calls for is get me out
of this little box where all I can do is
talk I want he's asking for cranes you
know a shots that like the one in
Atonement that goes all around like four
four cities and ends up in his nose I
mean he's you know there's there are
limits to what you can do with just
words and artists and writers have
always felt it and gestured toward it
and so the new generation has it and you
want to you know you want to welcome
that but I think that that as the word
so I mean your answer your question at
the gala mafia or hardwood mafia what
you what you're saying is that there's a
surprise the generation that made the
great television of the 80's 90's was
looking back was surprisingly well
educated and every now and then the New
York Times would run a piece saying look
there's a person there who writes for
television who actually knows how to
read and write and went to college ones
would always be shocking you know the
people i think that's you know people
know that you come out of brown and MIT
and so forth having watched and absorbed
a lot of internet webisodes and
television maybe even more than novels
by Balzac and yet you're you're you're
going to be creative and you're gonna
tell interesting stories but I think
there is some there there may be some
leakage and what we can accomplish when
we're no longer a logo centric I mean I
that is that just an old fogey maybe but
that one what I think one would
certainly I think one could certainly
say that recent television is less
verbal that it used to be less
psychological more oriented toward
action in ways that confirm what you're
saying well it also it's also image mad
I mean that's really because I mean dead
wood is a very verbal show there are
speeches in Deadwood that must go three
pages on the and yet you don't
necessarily I would not call a character
send it i would call it's very
interested in image making and and kind
of myth-making it's basically a very a
log oriya graphic novel it's not
actually
novelistic it's not literary dramatic
the way we're talking about what's a
really positive example Juno Juno seems
to me in the great literary tradition
that's depressing to hear no no I think
general is I think junos comes right out
of Jane Austen or something without
blinking I mean Juno assuming me a great
it's not as good as large in the real
girl but it's close i would say Lars and
the real girls the best script I've read
in the last seven or eight years and
tell you truth I didn't see the movie i
just read this crap she was a TV writer
on Six Feet Under terribly literary
shell with real characters and a total
and a completely absurd premise that you
would have if you were a betting person
you would have been well advised to bet
against the success of a show set in a
funeral parlor um and yet look at the
pleasure it gave and look at how much it
ended up saying about human beings and
life but of course in one of its Roger
cable show though yes that will add that
the less anything we say sir Hayden on
the network they said before when you
have something that's fundamentally
people-centered and use going to use
have to use language a lot you go to HBO
for instance and that would be an
example of why but it's no surprise that
that a writer on Six Feet Under ends up
writing wonderful script like Lars and
the real girl it's it's it's less
surprising the fact that a stripper ends
up writing you know but though those are
marvelous writers that's a very exciting
generation of women writers we got some
interesting shows ahead it's as good as
a squid and the whale is bad it's your
turn we have some we have a clip in
reserve which which I could show but I'm
holding it in case the discourse
requires it the reason it we should go
to questions is that the media comes at
you and now you get to come back a
little bit it would be helpful to
identify yourselves when you come to the
microphone since this is being recorded
for posterity hi there I'm Tom belviq
and I'm a media theorists enjoying this
so I have a question in reference to
television content over the last 10 20
30 years and my question is given the
rich spectrum of human drama that's
available I've always tend to think of
cops and robbers is kind of a least
common denominator approach to that
content so my question I guess is is is
the obsession with with cops and robbers
and crime drama is that a feature
function associated with the television
industry or their obsession with it the
audience's obsession with it or some
combination of between the two well I
think it's probably hardwired into the
human being ass obsession with cops and
robbers if by that you mean dramas that
centrally turn the question of whether
you're breaking the law or not Antigone
is centrally about that you'd be
breaking the law burying your brother
there that's okay I guess I'm a criminal
well I'm a cop says Creon and we got a
show to do so that's a cop that's that's
the first cop show in my imagination
when I was a student of literature on
and maybe we shave it and the word of
our guinea for these people David Thorin
was no now you're not caring about me
okay young professor David Thorburn it
was giving the lecture and he said we
were all students of I mean you know the
fashionable topics were theory the
factual topics were Rousseau we were
like you know and the poetry of Wallace
Stevens that's was that moment was the
70s in literary theory and um David's
gave a lecture professor Thorburn you
have a lecture that said a cop is a
really interesting person now he's
speaking to an audience who didn't think
so cops the other word for cop was Pig
and we were sure that they weren't very
interesting at least not the ones that
we had passed on the way to school that
morning and he said no a cop stands at a
windy
juncture of you know mind a little
rewriting you Windy corner we're
straight society and the element that
threatens it and poor people and people
who prey on poor people it stands at the
juncture of social forces economic
forces social forces it stands in a set
of Hobbesian cutting edge that person
and he has to live a life he has to come
home to his family he has to be a person
he said it's interesting that our
novelists our fiction writers at the
time that was conjured the name Donnell
Barthelemy or something are not
interested in a figure like that but if
you go back a hundred years Balzac
writes about comps Dickens writes
inspector bucket Dostoyevsky creates
stavrogin in in crime and punishment in
other words the great foundational works
of narrative fiction found cops very
interesting and saw their social the odd
social place they occupy is perfect for
a kind of narrative exploration of our
of the social contract of our deepest
issues while our novelists are now
pivoting off in the direction of Donnell
Barthelemy or excuse me Sylvia Plath and
and that that thing was so alarming and
reactionary and interesting that many of
us became cops show writers a non direct
causation but it stayed it occurred to
me very often and I knew it was true
athletes the Dickens so uh what I'm
saying is that that that the real
question is not why somebody people
watch cops and robbers is what else is
there to really write about not other
than cops and robbers but the
fundamental question of right and wrong
and society how we can stand living with
each other how can we get the good of
living with each other and what medium
more on it's like life and when you
write when you're writing a medical show
unless you're stealing money what you're
doing is you're supposed to be writing
about life and death so that if instead
you're just stealing hugs in the hallway
like on Grey's Anatomy I think you're
letting down our trust but life for
medical shows read life and death for
cops and robbers read read Hobbes
Leviathan for you know any of these
genres there's a reason we keep
that's what's hitting that's the that's
the pressure of thought that's hitting
them at an angle if you're any good at
it and if the show is any good so I
don't think they need much defending
most of them are terrible most cop shows
are terrible in spite of everything I
can every illusion I can drive I mean
what one further thing from an academic
or historical perspective to say about
these genre forms is that they're partly
because they're so stable the genre
begins the beginning of television
continues as one of its dominant Jon not
it's only genre one of its dominant
story forms it's a it makes the cop show
an incredibly interesting window on on
American social history because you can
see over the course of the history of
television the movement from dragnet in
the 1950s to show to various shows in
the in in the 60s culminating at the end
of the 60s in a series of cop shows that
show much greater sympathy I mean the
culture was bifurcated right it was the
time of the Vietnam War and generation
generational conflict and the cop shows
reflected that and they showed him the
cop shows of the late 60s and early 70s
through Hill Street Blues in 1980 which
begins in 1980 our shows that show a
much greater sympathy for the criminals
and a much greater sympathy for the
victims of crime have a much more
complex attitude toward a complex réseau
sympathy the social yes the social
pathology of crime becomes a subject and
then I think what you can actually see
as the country itself becomes more
conservative and in the Reagan years you
can see cop shows constricting again
going back to being much simpler kinds
of morality plays in which the couple
well well back to my original point
though the threats that the threats that
that that you know the such a thing is
being a reactionary the threats that
cause reaction also have to be taken
seriously if you're a good writer you
want to walk a line between
acknowledging what people are afraid of
that drive reaction and noting their
reactionary quality but when you're
doing CSI and you're only interested in
how with one strand of hair we can find
you even if you're in New Zealand then
you're then you're you're imagining that
there are that there are simple
solutions to complex problems
act with you so next question oh sorry I
just finished a huge paper on the CSI
effect oh um but another thing that I
noticed when I was writing this is the
theme that late night TV hmm seems to
really be about things that are
dangerous and fearful almost like fairy
tales when you say late night TV well
I've insomnia so there's a lot of shows
on you know after 11 12 1 2 3 that tend
to be about medical mysteries or you
know this could happen to you type of
things or America's Most Wanted true
crime you know predatory type behaviors
and I'm thinking you know this is the
last thing you want to see before you
sleep but yet maybe you could explain
that why they're on so why there aren't
so late yeah why that theme is so
prevalent in late night TV I think I
think there's a just a voyeurism and a
pornography to it that's just
unbelievable and the thing about it that
I would say to whoever makes those shows
mean I you know it's not the same group
they're not right they're not really
right or driven there you know they're
there documentary filmmakers and they're
sort of slumming most of them I know
what you mean like the tat even HBO had
one the taxi stories was that you ever
see that one yeah taxi diary taxi diary
is that it the thing about it is that
there'll always be you know they'll
always be and you know the walls of
Pompeii they'll always be an appetite
for that kind of and I think it's
preying on people's late-night fears and
under the guise of telling the truth and
getting at reality they're just
titillating are most worse of for am
sleepless anxieties they're not saying
anything about those things they're just
saying you know what they're kind of say
that kind of thing that's what they're
saying that's all they have to say look
at this and and all those fake those cop
shows which are just the camera
following arrests and domestic break-ins
and you know they're just giving people
a kind of vicarious thrill and the am I
warning to anyone who's putting
their money behind such shows is that
the Internet's doing it way better and
that we can't there's no way we can
compete you know we used to say about
violence I mean we used to pride
ourselves in Hill Street how bad we did
the action sequences because we just
didn't care about him and we weren't
very good in them and how do you write
them anyway and the thing that kept this
honest was that movies just did them so
much better you know you know how can
you compete with the explosiveness of a
die hard to name a really exciting
example you can't compete with that on
TV so don't even try and I would say to
these to that kind of TV you I think
your instincts about what's creating it
is correct correct there and they're not
very soothing is that you cannot keep up
with what the internet is is about to
provide is now providing so I think
they're for their doom that's a case
where the technological wars mean TV
will lose because no matter what how
permissive the FCC gets they're never
going to permit some of the stuff you
could find if you type in the right sick
little combination of words on your
search engine god help us thank you
thank you I think my name is Steven Bren
and I work in the advertising industry
I'd like to you touch your touched on
royalties briefly earlier I'd like to
kind of bring back bring us back to that
you know what I think about I think
about royalties and I I also think about
you know libraries a little bit and I
wonder you know when the libraries are
just sort of starting to understand the
role the internet plays and in their
ability to sort of bring the library
from a physical building out into the
home I know the Boston Public Library is
working through many initiatives as sort
of a sort of decentralized the library
and decentralize their collection and I
also look at you know BitTorrent for
example and the recent statistics have
been reading our eighty percent of the
traffic on BitTorrent are actually
television programs so I sort of look at
this spontaneous library of television
programming which is sort of you know
there's enormous demand and appetite
obviously it's illegal i think by any
standards that the writers would
certainly look at and I remember as a
child I go to library we get videotapes
and we go home and we watch them and we
bring them back and do you think that
down the road the royalty issue will
of inhibit live the library's ability to
deliver digital content well you know
how do you see that playing out sort of
down the road I mean obviously writers
need to make money and it's not just
writers obviously they have a financial
interest but you know even today we can
go and take out books and such free
library and and and you know I just like
to get your comments and yeah I mean I
hope you're not too disappointed I don't
have strong or interesting views on this
i mean i know that i know there's an
unpredictable a lot of unpredictable
aspects to the media the explosion the
types and kinds of of archiving and
library availabilities and i don't think
anyone can predict right now what's the
best arrangement let me make the
opposite case when the one I made before
because as I say I don't have religious
views on this I like the studios and
networks wanting to be in the dramatic
television business and the business of
making movies that are about human
beings instead of transformers I like
studios and networks to think there's
money to be made there and I don't want
to to use the jargon disincentivize an
executive who's considering a project by
taking away the little pennies he thinks
he might make in the by selling it in
some media that I can't even conceive
ever pronounce so I i think there's I'm
a no huge hurry to figure out
contractually how even if they invent a
way of you know watching my show on your
fingernail or something I will get money
pennies out of it I don't I don't need
to spend any time doing that we but
everybody in this room knows that the
Internet is a place to watch TV episodes
or you you'll soon know your kids your
kids will tell you and so that one we
know that there must be advertising
dollars that's what it comes to getting
getting spent on those internet
rebroadcast so how about you know
cutting that very big pie or if it's a
little pie cutting that very little pie
and then that's all that's as far as I
can go I can't and by the way I it's
true or authors don't get royalties when
I take your book out of the library and
no one's screaming that this is a
uh you know moral nefarious so mr. mana
my name is David sheets and I'm an
undergraduate here at MIT and I'm
wondering about to I guess related in my
mind relatively recent things that have
occurred it's related to the TV show
dexter on showtime yeah which is a cop
and robber show as you mentioned and
it's regarding the layout of the show
how the show is no longer metered and
fed to the audience episodic Lee weekly
like you mentioned you can view it on
DVD in fact many people that I talk to
only view their shows in the internet or
on DVD how do you think it's going to
change the writing of these shows
particularly shows that are very
traditional forms like cops and robbers
where you now have these very intricate
you know multi our video storylines like
in the show dexter that you have to keep
the entire show in your mind
simultaneously to understand well i
think that i mean i think it's very
exciting I think you know that narrative
has well two things one I still think
the most adventurous thing about Dexter
which is a good show is that it from the
point of view of a serial killer I mean
it's hard once you once that's you've
decided to cross that Rubicon and I
think here already and you know strange
territory and and um it's very good they
do a good job that makes sense to me the
show makes moral sense to me makes sense
to me Macbeth is about as the stars a
killer and indeed a serial killer but as
for what you're saying about the fact
that they're breaking it up and webbing
it out and all that and how does it
affect the writing of it I think that
we're trying to we're trying to keep up
and trying to figure it out i'm not on
the chelsea but i'm sure they're trying
to figure out how to are there three
minute version are the three minute
scenes which will get people to watch
the whole hour are there here's one
thing it's very tempting which is
there's a great scene to be had let's
say with the mother of the victim but
there's really no room in the hour for
that scene we want the hour to move move
move move move so if you go on to our
website and click on her little head
you'll see the scene that she plays out
with the
investigating investigator what's your
name and we didn't have room for it in
the show and then from that it's a short
step to let's shoot some scenes which
are not going to be in the hour that are
now going to be available online so if
you're really if it can't get enough a
loss like these three guys you can go
online and see you know what's your name
when she goes back to her ten or
something you can you can follow
rivulets off the main and we are writing
them and providing them and nice thing
is they don't have to be any given
length they don't have to be I mean
there's a that's very tempting to a
writer I mean you know we like to write
give us anything you know and the one
minutes of 24 those are cut from the
body but it's very easy to shoot us a
few more and you know we used the first
place it appeared I remember they gave
the Coppola did the deluxe pack of the
Godfather and he included scenes of the
family which were not in any version
including his cut it's not like the
director's cut it's stuff that he had
left on the cutting room floor well now
you're going to start making those
scenes and writing those things and
sometimes they'll include clues for the
ongoing story of the series the whole so
you're inviting the audience to play
with you fun fun fun no my reaction is
that it's fun I mean a further further
sort of theoretical implication is that
it continues a process that the literary
scholars have been talking about for
almost half a century now which is what
they call the destabilization of the
text where what is the text it is is it
is it the hour that's broadcast it is it
is it the director's cut that's reduced
letter that's or is it the is it the DVD
there are so many venues in which in
which these stories can now be
experienced that it's that it's
fundamentally altering the landscape of
this form of narrative and I think that
it's a profound question and I think
John's answer about how this is tempting
tells us how writers are going to begin
to exploit these new possibilities but I
there's one Cavill that there's one
caveat that I think is crucial which is
that we live in an era where platforms
go obsolete with f five minutes after
they're introduced and that is the
problem it was if if there were some
stability if we could be sure that a
particular delivery system would last
more than five years
we might have some confidence that very
rich forms of narrative would develop
but of course we're not sure about this
some of these here comes blue
experiments are going that's right some
of these experiments are going to be are
going to be disappointed because the
platform they are conceived for won't be
viable but in general were clearly in an
immensely destabilized moment in the in
the history of audio visual storytelling
and what John's just said about it is
just a hint of what what what I think
will follow hi my name is Whitney I'm a
first-year CMS graduate student I'm
really interested in the fact that you
have a background in Dickens and you've
talked a lot about the relationship
between literature and television
writing and sentimentality of course
Dickens being great sentimental writer
I'm also interested in the relationship
between of course Dickens is also a
great writer of cereal texts and wrote
in process he would write serials as you
know one at a time on a monthly basis
and I'm curious if you see any
relationships between that and
television writing it's something that
I've seen some Victorian scholars hint
at but not they haven't really fleshed
out a relationship that might exist you
don't mean the popularity of both
narratives actually that's a very good
question I mean it's a question I like a
lot feeling of to do about Dickens and
it's a very good question about the form
of television because I think that's
where it was predicted in some way was
was the weekly not only monthly but
weekly serialization in some of the
Victorian novels not just Dickens he's
the one we remember and not only that
but they would go home you know they'd
appear you'd buy buy a copy bring home
bring it home and read it to the family
in the living room just where we had the
TV now and not only that but it came
with commercials our advertiser friend
to be happy i mean the the if you look
at a serial weekly it had ads around the
side you know for powders and whatever
they sell and and and so it came with
commercials and also dickens watched the
sales of his story and if things were
not going well with the sales of a given
book like we might watch Nielsen's he
might just introduce a new character he
might change the direction of his story
and he watched him like a hawk in Martin
Chuzzlewit he
the people started for the first time
not to read his his new book in the same
numbers he was used to and he noticed
that a lot of bestsellers were about
voyages to America and so he suddenly
sent his characters off to America and
sales picked up and he brought them home
and finished the original narrative
which is just what a good Hollywood
producer might do you know this is
really working on some other show we
should have you know a I don't know
getting cooperative so there's a kind of
appetite for the audience which drives
the artistic imagination in the same way
as well as these really exact parallels
that you're pointing to such as weekly
civilization but the profoundest link is
the one you began with the
sentimentality and so forth this is
really a middle-class writer writing to
the heart of the middle class when that
wasn't a bad word and the emotions of
family and the drama as you saw in that
club of very ordinary human lives you
know everybody who's got a teenage
daughter or is one gets it and that was
fodder for his imagination and the
victorian imagination and it still plays
like mad you know so that yeah the
dickens it was a very appropriate
background i would have been a different
TV writer if I'd come out of flow bear
or something yes you know like I like
the question and the intimacy you know
your question about late night is
there's it there's a very private
relation between reader and text alone
in bed at 2am that's not the relation at
eight o'clock or nine o'clock TV show
when you're watching with your kids
you're always told to watch with your
children when you're eating in front of
the TV so the communal meal becomes but
the relationship between you and the TV
set at 3am you're probably watching
alone and these days you might even be
watching with the with it on your lap in
the world of laptops and and I think
there's it's so it draws closer to that
other the solitary relation of the
reader and the the 19th century novel
had already moved away from that too
kind of more public engagement but
that's one thing that's going on with
late night isn't it reminds me of
listening as a kid to radio shows and by
putting you know putting the radio under
my pillow and listening to a voice late
at night now TV is there whereas TV
stations in those days had signed off
with the American flag at around
ten-thirty is our hi my name is Wesley
Foster I'm a computer engineer and has
anyone realized that the function of
video is to make hardware more
marketable is what the function of video
is to make hardware more marketable I
know I didn't tell me about that well
Microsoft sells most of its units
directly to the actual factory and just
charges name a licensing fee in other
words if they hit sued by a legal body
that wants to extort money out of them
they just simply get rid of the retail
version and they sit there and say okay
now you can buy it from the Japanese and
you can pay somebody to take it off and
it's your problem not mine haha and up
until Linux or the eee pc you couldn't
really market a piece of pc without a
windows operating system on it so the
function the model for the engineering
community and computer engineering is
that without the actual windows
operating system the pc is unmarketable
as I mass-produced device so the object
of our industry is to reduce the cost of
memory to the point where we can first
market audio which we've done with
Napster and so on and then lower it
further by marketing video so the
logical aspiration for our industry is
to take video put it onto a notebook pc
at the factory and used the program on
the pc to make the pc marketable because
the profit level is so much higher in
the actual hardware because you have to
write a piece of software once and then
you can market it millions of times that
comparing the actual product alone sold
on is on a CD or dvd is unprofitable you
might as well just shove it on the
Virtual PC at the factory
has anybody in the industry realize that
yeah I mean it's a kind well say yes and
even know I hardly know you're talking
about but the truth is that no I mean I
don't mean esoterically what I mean is I
do not know how close such a development
would be or how it would look but I can
say yes to this extent it sounds like
very bad news I could say yes in this
exam we are terrified about the kind of
thing you're talking about are we
correct to be terrified in your opinion
sounds like we should be it means your
markets going to get wider not not more
narrow if I would get worried I what I
read about it I would be the executive
who was worried at NBC because if I was
the head of the Union during the union
negotiations I would have gone to the
Chinese and say can you make a player so
like in circumvent NBC and have all of
my union members produce content for
your device instead of an actual
television set well if I understand you
correctly though I should be terrified
too because if if if people are going to
buy a pc that already has all my movies
22 episodes of my favorite show or
whatever once and forever they bought
that they'll never get through what they
have on their hard drive i imagine in
their lifetime right then they never
have to go to the store and buy the DVD
DVD of any of those things and i'll
never see any profit royalty
participation or residuals because they
bought it if i understand you it's like
I guess my ignorance up front but if i
understand you it's already in there
sodium the pc that i buy so why would
that person ever have to go to a store
or theater to see anything that you were
i'm i right well what ends up happening
is you end up with well written shows
that have a very large market
internationally available and i think if
you talk to the rest of Star Trek I
think they're probably pretty pleased
but they're exactly good you know what I
pictured when you tell me about it again
without having quite the ability to
understand uh there's that collection of
Janus Films which is 250 see
you can buy which are all the great
foreign films that were marketed here in
the 60s and 70s and it's very heavy and
very expensive more expensive than my
wife intends to spend on me at Christmas
and I imagine that what you're saying
you could buy someday that'll just be on
somebody's hard drive is a little a
little attractive little perk of buying
the thing and those films would be
available you know the way it's very
hard to find them or buy them now so
it's good for the consumer and good for
ya and maybe maybe even I mean yeah the
shelf life is good we'll see it's so far
being so not what we do it's so far
beyond imagination we know just enough
to be afraid it's not I'm trying to
convey it's hard to take this as a
serious business model because since the
since the computer is a system that can
communicate with anyone it makes more
sense to think of it as a device that
would allow people to buy many stories
from any day many different sources are
saying you'll never have to but I mean
if the idea is that that you can buy
every audio visual story in the history
of the universe on a single CD that's a
different matter but I assume that even
if that were true they poke it would be
put up someplace on the net and you
could go and download what you wanted
right makes much more sense than that
every individual in the universe should
own every story ever written in the
universe it's hard for me to see why one
would ignore the pc's communication
power its power to reach you i'm not me
telling people that you about this sure
thing why do you know yeah you have your
cell phone sitting in front of you right
if you look at the cost of that and
reply the standard business model that
device is going to cost you four
thousand dollars over a four-year period
that is more expensive than every pc
that most of us will own and
unfortunately there's nothing in it that
is even significant enough to go on your
resume it is a device that's going to be
used for marketing something the aim for
our computer industry is to market video
we're going to be looking for video to
market our compact flash cards are about
to hit 32 gigs on the market there's 64
gigs on the way the SSD drive is
available
although hideously overpriced our hard
drive and you saying what implication is
that bandwidth won't be more catch up
enough so that you could so the amount
of download and you could do wouldn't be
enough to match what you could get the
object of the industry is to lower the
cost of memory that I guess a lot of it
is done by simply wasting a lot of it
well have to come a new start it you
don't how specifically designed not to
use it very well right and occasionally
screw up yes we build IBM mainframes and
IBM mainframe tests and use everything
in it exactly and we'll give you ever
report on what's broken in it eventually
we'll get to that in a cell phone but
first we got to get the costumer me down
to do that we need you to produce video
so we're going to need good writing
we're gonna need video production don't
think of tv's your only market oh yeah I
know yeah that that's a good is the good
news and you have to understand when I
graduated from college in 1999 I was
allowed 12 Meg's on a unix server that
was it that's the space of three mp3's
the cards nowadays are two thousand
times that size I can walk in put my
credit card down and walk out with it my
professors never dreamed that would be
possible okay hi I'm Anna of first year
student at CMS up at what CMS
comparative Media Studies um I I just
wanted to know how you've dealt with
product placement and how you've seen it
evolved as I think it's I had an intense
experience with it because the last show
where I was just a consultant sort of
mostly more in movies and on TV now it
comes up in movies but on it would never
reach down to the level level of the
mere writer but in TV we had an American
Dreams the we had a very aggressive
executive producer who was keeping it
keeping the show on the air by going
directly to Ford and
and general mills and you know we'd be
pouring that cereal would be driving
those cars and you'd write it right into
the text and somehow you'd find a way of
saying the product name and I found it
really boring to have to do that but you
know what people do say product names
sometimes so I guess it's not beyond the
capacity of a writer to work it in there
you don't want you got enough to think
about without worrying about without
having to reference the you know captain
crunch but it's you know but its present
it's there it is it more prevalent now
just well yeah sure everything
everything that involves ways of
affording television shows is more
prevalent now in movies it's really
buried it's in movies it's still thank
goodness i think in the realm of what
what things are on the shelf in the
kitchen you know behind Harrison Ford's
head it's still a matter of things you
see that you may not be paying into I
haven't heard anyone say that's a swell
chevrolet you're driving there harrison
when when you start hearing that you
know that it's reached movies too but
it's not something writers like to find
themselves doing and it is real but you
know what Peter Barca has been very good
to every summer television and movies
John every time I see an apple computer
on television I wonder if Apple has paid
figure well I mean but the truth is
there you're limited i'm sitting here i
can see two apple computers right i mean
so that you know it's like I always I
mean I don't smoke I've never smoked but
I hated like heck being told that my
characters can't smoke there are certain
people who are going to smoke your job
is your a night watchman and a bank and
downtown Boston you know and just walk
around the block all night you're a fool
not to smoke I mean you know I mean and
the idea that so I mean I've never liked
being told any of that stuff it makes I
understand you know people died of
emphysema shouldn't sound its way but
you don't want you know as a writer you
imagine things you see things you'd love
to see them on the screen
um well maybe what we'll do now is we
have a few minutes left about 15 minutes
left maybe what I'll do is there was a
clip I was withholding I think we'll
show a clip and have John make a quick
comment about it what is this is a scene
from Hill Street Blues it's it's a sin
trying to persuade buns to the this the
scene is between a snitch and a cop can
we do third watch again as you okay wait
wait it's too long
yeah that's nice honey gets money okay
it says you're in plumbing supply and
can't stop in a second man yeah um I
guess you have to explain what we're
looking at come in the light John so
they can see you um this scene which I
don't know where David gets the seams
but this scene was from the first
episode of the last season of Hill
Street and in it's about two scenes into
this episode what has happened is that a
plane has crashed in the in the in the
bad part of town and as a small
passenger plan small private plane and
as the cops have cleared it out a snitch
and informant for the police has grabbed
a suitcase which seemed to have fallen
out of the debris of the plane and run
like mad and he goes to dennis franz one
of the great people you'll ever work
with or no and he's the informant for
the detective months the and he's
telling him that he may know something
about where that suitcase says whichever
one is of course looking for in the city
the imaginary city where he'll street
blues take place so we've just seen the
plane crash we saw a hand grab the
suitcase and somebody run and then we're
in the bar with detective Bunce who's a
cop and his informants it on the left
they put 25 G's up each nostril that's
the curse until how many lives have seen
if you try to get business back on its
feet again based on here here comes the
sniper niche know and that's what we do
I think you better get out of here I
think he may be hot
I start you pretend we get two points a
week extra to every month outstanding
right okay you knows how to get ahold of
I guess pop cause you I'm going to feed
your freaking eyes
oh can you make it happen for me said
wait where we said I'm going to see what
I can do excuse me since when did you
get to be captain on the store bro sup
norm go Bobby crazy my writing on I just
blow our connect with a shy but I'm
trying to set you up with what three
weeks now and now Norman I'm laying
hands on you so this is how you gotta
know what is coming to our lives norm is
so big it's so powerful long or else I
don't take the shot tell me about the
suitcase did you see that suitcase yes
did you see what I can't bend over with
we do that thing do you know what was in
it uncut direct from a near disaster not
a pound man which a pound uncut streets
for 20 20 25 but it's not a pound and
it's not in pounds more which 10 pounds
conservative moves at a deuce in six
digits and gets two people how'd it is
stinking rat hole and set up by water we
could think not domestic water nor did i
say domestic orders because it doesn't
have to be domestic water norm we could
set up by any water in a whole kitchen
world it's not 10 pounds more that's not
the amount that's not 20 pounds norm
which 20 pounds norm gets odds and
limousines and a house anywhere you
could pay go and not 40 past not even
six pounds norm which is three-quarters
of a million dollars
intestines were dying his testicles
would await our game I am going to ask
you a question once I don't think you
would respect me as a man if I didn't
that Bobby is announced she is looking
to off to stop for high four figures
7510 grand max 10 grand and knowing the
kind of person you are I wouldn't be
surprised if you'll have that in the
bank accounts or am i right that Bobby
is added a picture and you can be normal
but struggling like this well that's the
base between I know that you are in more
enforcement but I'm here can you as a
human being to consider the possibility
of an entire fresh concept and start in
life okay I'm gonna take my hand away
from your lips now it would mean knowing
so much to me if you gave me some
positive indication that you would
consider what I am suggesting still
glimmer not do any possibility
in a sense of what meaning come and come
to hear what I was hoping you might do
John is coming in a sort of general way
on the world of the scene and I don't
know two guys this is written by two
guys who don't look terribly unlike
these two guys you know 20 years ago I'm
we're just sitting in a French
restaurant where we had lunch every day
while doing Hill Street Blues and just
we were like saying maybe he says to him
maybe we keep the suitcase and then it
went from there to like well don't
answer right away but maybe we keep the
suitcase and then it went to now I'm
going to ask you a question and brain
just started building and we were on the
floor by the time we were done you know
coming up with I'm going to take my
hands away no III didn't you wouldn't
respect this line we thought was funny
assist you wouldn't respect me if I
didn't at least ask and you know where
we're left we're making ourselves crazy
with laughing and then we go back and
type it up what do you want well one
thing I thought you might comment on is
is the relationship between the cop and
his shrink but and his stand on his
snitch I've been thinking about in
treatment and his snitch because it's
obviously this is obviously a complex
friendship isn't yeah and and and you
know if any of you know anything about
this kind of law enforcement the
relation informants are very the
relationship between a performance and
detectives is a very steep moral and
psychological territory you know you
you're clearly choosing someone who's up
to his ears in crime or her and you owe
a responsibility to protect them but
they also owe you a great deal for not
doing what you can do which is you know
arrest them or something so there's a
kind of sense in which we both have each
other at each other's mercy and you but
you are fundamentally a cop and I am
fundamentally a
criminal and there's that kind we built
over the years a relationship between
these two which was especially nodded
and and kind of mutually affectionate
they resemble each other but they don't
and they live together I mean I'm sure
that queer theory would have a ball with
the sort of homoerotic overtones they
live together they love each other I
remember I wrote the last episode of
Hill Street Blues co-wrote and there's a
scene which is the next to last episode
an xls seen the show where bunts is
being kicked off that Detective is being
kicked off the force for losing his
temper and and hitting the police chief
in the face and whenever he um he's
sitting alone well with the fact that
he's going to lose his profession as a
confidence always ever wanted to be and
Sid his who had this the star moment
here his informant it you know it comes
to him and tries to comfort him and
bunch says I don't see myself being a
cop again and it's just so such a pained
moment and Sid says some you're the best
you're the best guy I ever knew which is
as close as people like this come to a
two-cent him in town to sentimentality
and I you know one says thanks and I'm
gonna go for a walk now and he leaves
and my boss at the time loved the scene
and I'm didn't change a word but he he
stopped the only thing he did was as
buns to identify the ball as David
Miller you how's your emails and the
only thing he did to the scene was right
before bun sleeves after having Sid
saying I'm you're the best guy ever knew
he says oh and if you pass a convenience
store can you pick me one of those pick
up one of those orange pops and an bun
says if I think of it you know if it's
if they're open or something like that
and he leaves was the only change but it
was brilliant change and it taught me a
lot I was a new writers my first show
because it had a kind of not that not so
much that it cut the treacle of the
sentiment
ality of the moment because that was
untouched I mean in a sense you couldn't
but because it was an irrelevant detail
it was just a sort of thing that just
happens in life and is just stuck to we
don't the scenes we play in real life no
matter what the scene is you know you're
told your wife is leaving you or
whatever whatever the scene is it never
happens without a little orange popping
it you know without something the phone
rings and it's a it's a solicitation you
know from Hillary Clinton's campaign or
something right in the middle of the
most dramatic moment of your life you
know that kind of thing in Flex we don't
get to play out the scenes of our life
in under a proscenium arch with perfect
artistic timing and that kind of
knowledge and TVs shoddy little form is
very good at at at conveying so that was
but that's what that tells you more
about the relationship between these
these two guys and I mean it was a you
know it was a violent show it
wasn't you know great art by all
standards but but you were able to
explore human human emotions and usual
you Minh na relations and I hope a
little bit redeem the and also you know
the tone of that show was especially
complicated because it was full of comic
weird strange unexpected moments like
this but that's history and I think we
should look forward to what you know
what television might be and in the
future and and and what movies might be
and I see this young generation of
filmmakers um making movies that are
really the smallest or about something
they have much more to do with john
sayles and they do what david milch mean
they're much more to do with with making
movies in your backyard with unknown
actors um telling stories about what you
really know this is really exciting
they're fresh they have a lot of heart
they're so far a little mild they can go
much further you know and they drift off
into a kind of easy calm and you think
of the Wilson brothers you know really
good kids who gone from the that kind of
film on describing like bottle rocket
two very big broad Hollywood comedies
that you know are seem to be less
interesting so there's a danger that
they'll sell out like so many before
them but in general there's something
about this generation of as I was saying
Nancy Oliver and
and the filmmakers of some of these
smaller comedies that that that I I
expect great storytelling great
narrative great human truth I don't know
what their economic and technological
future is but um you can't keep people
from telling stories when I see this I
see something that strikes me is really
funny very old-fashioned very and and
but but but but paved the way for a kind
of truth and honesty and in storytelling
it's not it's not it's not a bed it's
not a bed it's a bad time for the big
Hollywood movies and it's a bad time for
the big hits I don't think there's a lot
about you know Grey's Anatomy or
something that I would that would excite
my artistic appetite if I were a young
filmmaker I wouldn't be rushing out to
direct an episode of that and then
businesses mostly that lipstick jungle
god help us you know I mean you know the
law will always be a lot of crap but I
think there's but there's also little
corners of both movies and less often
television where you could see people
coming along and saying something new
and so they don't come out of literature
and theatre and things the way the way
we did there's still stories stories to
tell so you know I really do feel
positive about what the new crop of
filmmakers will do thank you very much
audience thank you John thank you
you